meine damen und herren unsere fraktion
hatte beim infektionsschutzgesetz von
anfang an das ziel den gesundheitsschutz
vor allem für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer zu stärken und für mehr
einheitlichkeit und nachvollziehbarkeit
bei den maßnahmen zu sorgen das haben
wir geschafft
darauf haben wir uns konzentriert und
von nichts und von niemandem haben wir
uns in diesen tagen davon ablenken dass
meine damen und herren
und deswegen ist es gut dass wir das
home-office gestärkt haben
das home office dient eben mit dazu zu
diesen kontakt beschränkungen zu kommen
aber es schafft eben auch den
gesundheitsschutz für die
arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer und
ich habe es sehr bedauert dass
eigentlich die möglichkeiten die
arbeitgeber gehabt hätten nämlich home
office in einer größeren zahl zur
verfügung zu stellen nicht freiwillig
gemacht haben sie haben es zu
verantworten dass wir das jetzt in
dieses gesetz haben dringen müssen es
ist noch luft nach oben und ich bitte
die arbeitgeber dies jetzt auch endlich
zu nutzen und zum anderen das
testangebot jetzt zweimal die woche für
die arbeitnehmerinnen und arbeitnehmer
die in die betriebe kommen müssen ist
wichtig und ich frage mich schon warum
wird das immer noch von dem einen oder
anderen in den unternehmensverbänden
hinterfragt es ist doch nicht nur eben
ein schutz für die arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmern sondern für das
unternehmen es kann dann weiter
wirtschaften und diese konsequenz haben
wir jetzt auch in dieses gesetz getragen
meine damen und herren ich bin froh und
der bundesfinanzminister hat es in der
vergangenen woche zum nachtragshaushalt
angekündigt wir wollen zwei milliarden
euro in die hand nehmen um ein aufholen
paket auf den weg zu bringen weil kinder
und jugendliche brauchen unsere
unterstützung wir brauchen auch wenn wir
medizinisch gesundheitspolitisch die
pandemie ein
staaten hilfen für diejenigen die auf
der strecke bleiben deswegen ist
außerschulische hilfe ist die
einbeziehung der kinder und jugendhilfe
sind freizeitangebote so wichtig umgeben
das wieder gutzumachen was wir eben auch
kindern und jugendlichen angetan haben
ja und wenn ich das hier vielleicht mal
in der realität liegen auch etwas nahe
bringen kann
was ist die situation ein kölner ein
einliter einer kölner grundschule wusste
vor einiger zeit zu berichten dass eben
kinder sich doch nicht testen lassen nun
er ist dem nachgegangen und warum haben
sich die kinder nicht testen lassen
naja weil die eltern eben nicht das
wollten weil sie dann angst um ihren
arbeitsplatz gehabt hätten wenn sie in
quarantäne hätten gehen müssen und das
ist die realität und deswegen wenden wir
uns genau denjenigen zu die so viel leid
auch ertragen müssen und ich bin dankbar
wenn das kabinett nächste woche diese
frage beschließen wird und meine damen
und herren wir bringen das
kinderkrankengeld noch mal zu einer
wesentlichen stärkung für die familien
die eben keine betreuung für ihre kinder
gewährleisten können und insbesondere
diese maßnahme ist wichtig um
finanzielle unterstützung zu leiten und
auf der anderen seite ja kollege tournee
genau das ist jetzt auch in diesem
gesetz verankert der deutsche bundestag
wird sich eben wenn die verordnung
ansteht und wenn wir sicher sind dass
geimpfte nicht mehr das virus übertragen
wird sich der deutsche bundestag eben
mit dieser verordnung befassen und das
ist wichtig dass eine große kompetenz
die die volksvertreterinnen und
volksvertreter hier einzubringen haben
meine damen und herren und zum zum
schluss in dieser frage wird auch ein
neuer rechtsweg für die bürgerinnen und
bürger eingezogen in diesem gesetz
nämlich über eine vorbeugende
feststellungsklage können die
bürgerinnen und
bürger eben auch schon gegenmaßnahmen
wie sie unmittelbar betreffen vorgehen
der schaffen rechtssicherheit
rechtsklarheit und wir schaffen eine
nachvollziehbarkeit der maßnahmen meine
damen und herren die pandemie hat unsere
gesellschaft und jeden einzelnen von uns
geprägt und deswegen danke ich dank
meine fraktionen dem bundespräsidenten
dass er eine würdige eine angemessene
trauerfeier am vergangenen wochenende
hat veranstalten lassen es war
insbesondere nicht nur eine trauerfeier
für die toten nicht nur eine trauerfeier
für die genesenen und nicht nur eine
trauerfeier für die familienangehörigen
die eben auch noch einmal abschied
nehmen konnten von der irren
verstorbenen sondern es war auch eine
trauerfeier für uns für die gesunden
weil wir an teilnehmen konnten an den
leit an dem schicksal was diese pandemie
für dieses land bedeutet was nicht durch
gesetze aus der welt gebracht werden
kann und deswegen muss ich sagen finde
ich unwürdig wie sich einige hier in
diesem tiefs verstörenden augenblick
verhalten
es ist nicht nur unanständig sondern es
ist unwürdig gegenüber den betroffenen
nun gegenüber den familien angehörigen
dass sie davon faseln dass die pandemie
herbei getestet wurde
gehen sie in die krankenhäuser reden sie
mit den familienangehörigen die ihre
angehörigen verloren haben
reden sie mit den pflegekräften die sich
aufopferungsvoll in dieser pandemie
dieser pandemie auch entgegenstemmen
sie haben die gefahr klein geredet in
diesem haus und sie haben die schuldig
gemacht in der pandemie weil nämlich
dadurch auch menschen die situation
auch vernachlässigt haben es ist
ungeheuerlich dass sie sich auf das
grundgesetz berufen verfassungsfeinde
haben sie schon einmal der verfassungs
bemächtigt und wir meine damen und
herren werden uns dem entgegen schlimm
vielen dank